COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY
MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
THEY HAVE A HEAVY LIFT.
GREAT SEGMENT, GUYS.
DAN AND RICHARD THANKS SO
MUCH.
THE DEMOCRATS AS I SAID SEEM
TO HAVE NO INTEREST IN
WORKING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
ON CULTURAL ISSUES OR
ANYTHING FOR THAT MATTER.
IS THAT GOOD POLITICS?
NOT ACCORDING TO A POLL I
MENTIONED JUST A SHORT WHILE
AGO.
NEW PRIVATE POLL CONDUCTED
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEE AS REPORTED BY
AXIOS.
THEY FOUND THAT DEMOCRATS
RUNNING IN THESE SWING
DISTRICTS QUOTE MUST EXPRESS
A WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
AS I SAID.
WELL, JOINING ME NOW FOR
REACTION IS SHELBY STEEL, A
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE HOOVER
INSTITUTION.
DR. STEEL, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOOD.
I'M GOOD.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Laura: DOES THAT SURPRISE
YOU THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE
AN UNWILLINGNESS ON THE PART
OF DEMOCRATS ON THE ISSUE OF
THE PRESIDENT MOVING FROM
DACA KIDS FROM 800,000 KIDS
WHO WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
AMNESTY, DR. STEEL, TO
1.8 MILLION WOULD HAVE
RECEIVED AMNESTY UNDER THE
TRUMP PROPOSAL.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE END AS
I PREDICTED SAID NOT GOING
TO DO IT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE IS THE SOURCE OF THEIR
POWER AND ON THE AMERICAN
LEFT.
I THINK HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
SUPPORTING POLICIES THAT WIN
THEM A KIND OF INNOCENCE IN
THE CULTURE THAT PUT THEM ON
THE SIDE OF THE GOOD SHOW
THEM TO BE REDEEMING,
RACIST, SEXIST, SO FORTH
PAST.
SO THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR IN BILLS LIKE
THIS AND IN MUCH OF WHAT
THEY PURSUE TODAY BECAUSE
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT IS
THAT AMERICA HAS MORALLY
GROWN IN THE LAST 50 YEARS.
IT IS NOT THE RACIST SOCIETY
THAT I GREW UP IN, FOR
EXAMPLE.
TODAY, IT IS -- YOU CAN SAY
THAT THE OPPRESSION OF
MINORITIES IS OVER WITH IT'S
SIMPLY SYSTEMIC PART.
THIS PULLS THE RUG OUT FROM
LIBERALS.
THEY HAVE NO MANDATE THAN TO
RECTIFY HISTORY AND RECTIFY
THE PAST.
THEY ARE A BIT EXHAUSTED AT
THIS POINT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
NEXT.
STEPHON CLARKE FUNERAL I
MENTIONED.
AL SHARPTON FLIES IN.
HE GETS UP AND SPEAKS AT THE
FUNERAL.
PEOPLE ARE VERY IMPASSIONED.
HE SAID I FLEW HERE
3,000 MILES ONLY FOR THIS
FAMILY AND TO KEEP THIS
GOING.
WE HAVE A SOUND BITE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS TO SAY THIS IS A
LOCAL ISSUE IS THE MAIN
REASON THAT MANY OF US SAID
NO MATTER WHAT, WE WILL BE
HERE.
THIS IS NOT A LOCAL ISSUE.
IT'S A NATIONAL PROBLEM.
>> Laura: IT'S A NATIONAL
PROBLEM.
NOW, WE WILL SEE WHAT THE
FACTS OF THIS CASE
ULTIMATELY SHOW.
BUT WHETHER IT WAS TRAYVON
MARTIN OR MICHAEL BROWN OR
FREDDIE GRAY.
EACH HORRIBLE INNOCENT ENDED
UP RACIAL SLASH POINT
REGARDLESS WHAT THE ULTIMATE
FACTS DETERMINED,
DR. STEELE.
>> WELL, THE FLASH POINT, IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A FLASH
POINT, SHOULD BE
MR. SHARPTON SHOULD FLY TO
CHICAGO WHERE IN 2016762
YOUNG BLACK LARGELY BOYS
SHOT BY OTHER BLACK BOYS
COMMITTED THAT MANY MURDERS
IN ONE YEAR WHERES THAT
LIBERAL SHARPTON AGAIN.
AGAIN, LIBERALISM GOES AFTER
EXAMPLES OF VICTIMIZATION.
WHAT'S AMAZING ABOUT
MR. SHARPTON HE HAS A
PASSION FOR BLACK